One of our radio show's producers, Jonathan, went driving around after the snowstorm this week with this family friend.
我们电台节目的一位制作人乔纳森，本周在暴风雪过后和这位家庭好友一起开车到处转。
We're heading down into a neighborhood where I started all this. That's when I got my first snow plow. And I think the karma thing started there.
我们正前往我最初开始这一切的街区。那时候我刚有了第一台扫雪机。我觉得因果报应的事情就是从那里开始的。
This guy was working for a school. It was his job to plow the parking lot. And just as a lark, he began to do a few of the neighbors' driveways also. And it totally won people over. It actually made him a friend. It made the school look good with its neighbors.
这家伙当时为一所学校工作。他的工作是清扫停车场。出于心血来潮，他也开始顺便帮邻居清扫车道。这完全赢得了人们的好感。这不仅让他交到了朋友，也让学校在邻居眼中留下了好印象。
And then, after that, long after he quit that job, he'd be driving around in the middle of the night, plowing driveways for a couple dozen people who would pay him for the service. And he also, just for free, would plow the driveways of people that he liked and for old people he didn't think should be shoveling and for people who he thought just deserved it.
在那之后，他辞掉那份工作很久了，他还是会在半夜开车到处转，为两三打付钱给他的人清理车道。而且他还免费为他喜欢的人、他认为不该铲雪的老人，以及他觉得理应得到帮助的人清扫车道。
He tells this story about how, a couple years ago, he was riding around with his motorcycle, and he ran out of gas. And he knocked on a stranger's door.
他讲过一个故事，说是几年前他骑摩托车到处转，结果汽油耗尽了。他敲开了一位陌生人的门。
And this really nice Chinese lady answered her door. And I told her I ran out of gas with my bike. Could I leave it there? And I was prepared to walk home. And she offered the gas. She said, I have gas for my lawn mower. Will it work for your motorcycle?
一位非常友好的中国女士开了门。我告诉她我的摩托车没油了。我可以把车放在这儿吗？我已经准备好走回家了。她主动提出提供汽油。她说，我有割草机用的油，这对你的摩托车有用吗？
She saved him from a five-mile walk home late at night.
她让他免于深夜步行五英里回家。
So I did her driveway for her for two years. And she never knew that I did it, I don't think.
所以我帮她清理了两年车道。我不认为她知道是我做的。
Why didn't you tell her that you were doing this?
你为什么不告诉她你在做这些事呢？
I didn't think I needed to do that. I don't know. I didn't want to creep her out or anything. I just did it like that.
我觉得没必要这么做。我不知道。我不想让她感到害怕或是别的什么。我就是那样做了。
So that's what he would do if you likes you. If you crossed him, he would mete out snowy, icy justice, like he did with one of his customers who decided not to pay him for a couple plows, stiffed him.
如果你对他好，他就会这样对你。如果你得罪了他，他就会实施冰雪般的正义，就像他对待其中一位决定不为几次清扫付费的客户那样，他被耍了。
You know, that six inches of snow at the end of her driveway, I can't tell you how many times that became 12 or 18 inches. And it wasn't from mother nature. It was from me. Drop a little present, you know? Some snow, a little extra for them. A little payback there.
你知道，车道尽头那六英寸厚的雪，我简直没法告诉你那是多少次变成了12或18英寸厚。那可不是大自然的杰作。是我干的。留点小礼物，你知道吗？多给他们一点雪，一点额外的“回馈”。在那儿给点报复。
It would be nice if we all had a snowplow fairy out there for every part of our lives, shoveling out street justice while we all sleep. We don't, of course. Usually, the best that any of us can hope for is that everyone around us will get what they deserve, that they'll reap what they sow, and things will work themselves out in a way that rewards the right people and punishes the other people.
如果我们在生活的每个方面都有一个扫雪仙子，在我们睡觉时铲除街头的正义，那该多好。当然，我们没有。通常我们所能期望的最好的结果是，我们周围的人都能得到他们应得的，种瓜得瓜，种豆得豆，事情会以奖赏好人、惩罚恶人的方式自行解决。
Today on our radio program, we have two stories where we watch that play out. In one story, an entire state tries something bold, and then everybody in the state has to live with the shakeout. In the other, consequences include two live chickens. From WBEZ-Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
今天在我们的广播节目中，我们有两个故事，我们可以看到这种情况的发生。在一个故事中，整个州尝试了一些大胆的举措，然后州里的每个人都不得不承担后果。在另一个故事中，后果包括两只活鸡。来自WBEZ-芝加哥，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Alien Experiment. The Obama administration has deported undocumented immigrants at a greater rate than any previous administration. It was 392,862 immigrants in 2010, over a million since he took office, which means that he's on track to deport more people in four years than the Bush administration did in eight. The Obama administration has also issued 10 times more in fines to employers who knowingly hire illegal workers.
第一幕，外来实验。奥巴马政府驱逐无证移民的比例比以往任何一届政府都要高。2010年是392,862名移民，自他上任以来超过一百万人，这意味着他在四年内驱逐的人数有望超过布什政府八年的总和。奥巴马政府还对故意雇佣非法劳工的雇主开出了十倍以上的罚款。
But as a country, we are still in this weird limbo of having no coherent or effective national strategy to deal with the 11 million people who are in the country illegally. For a long time, there's been two camps when it comes to this issue. There's the zero tolerance people, who want to round them all up and kick them all out. And then there are other people who want leniency, a pathway to citizenship.
但作为一个国家，我们仍然处于这种尴尬的困境中，对于国内1100万非法居留的人没有一个连贯或有效的国家策略。长期以来，在这个问题上存在两个阵营。一种是“零容忍”派，他们想把所有人都抓起来并驱逐出境。还有其他人则希望采取宽容态度，提供通往公民身份的途径。
But now there is this third way. There's this new movement that has popped up in states like Arizona and Alabama. It's formally called attrition through enforcement. But casually, proponents use a phrase that you may have heard, self-deportation. The idea is, make life so difficult, so unpleasant for illegal immigrants, that they choose to go home. They self-deport. Jack Hitt went to the place that has been trying this out since October, Alabama.
但现在有了第三种方式。这是一个在亚利桑那州和阿拉巴马州等地涌现出的新运动。它正式被称为“通过执法实现减员”。但非正式地，支持者使用了一个你可能听说过的短语：自我驱逐。其理念是，让非法移民的生活变得如此困难、如此不愉快，以至于他们选择回国。他们自我驱逐。杰克·希特去了自十月份以来一直在尝试这种做法的地方：阿拉巴马州。
When Arizona passed its notorious immigration bill in 2010, there was outrage and a national debate about whether it had crossed some constitutional line. Then, last summer, Alabama went way, way beyond that, passing the most sweeping immigration bill in the country. I went down there, hearing that the law was causing no small amount of chaos. I wondered if they'd accidentally created more problems for themselves than they'd solved.
当亚利桑那州在2010年通过其臭名昭著的移民法案时，引发了愤怒和关于它是否越过了宪法底线的全国性辩论。然后，去年夏天，阿拉巴马州走得更远，通过了该国最严厉的移民法案。我去了那里，听说这部法律引起了不小的混乱。我想知道他们是否在无意中为自己制造了比解决的问题更多的问题。
You may have seen reports of desperate farmers complaining that their crops were rotting in the fields. Tomatoes, blueberries, squash, unpicked as workers fled the state. Members of the military who couldn't prove citizenship were frustrated in the simplest thing, like registering a boat. The Alabama Department of Revenue sidestepped certain provisions of the law so people wouldn't be thrown out of their homes. Frightened Latino parents kept thousands of students home from schools. Outraged principals rose up against the law. A 12-year-old I met, named Stephanie, told me about an assembly in her school.
你可能看过绝望的农民抱怨他们的农作物在田里腐烂的报道。番茄、蓝莓、南瓜，因为工人逃离该州而无人采摘。无法证明公民身份的军人甚至在注册船只这样简单的事情上也感到沮丧。阿拉巴马州税务局回避了法律的某些条款，以免人们被赶出家园。受惊的拉丁裔家长让成千上万的学生留在家里不去上学。愤怒的校长们起来反对这项法律。我遇到的一位名叫斯蒂芬妮的12岁孩子告诉我她学校里的一次集会。
They started talking about how they're going to take illegal Mexicans out of school. They were talking about that if they do take our parents, we're OK, because they could send us to Mexico with them. Almost everybody was crying.
他们开始谈论他们要如何把非法墨西哥人赶出学校。他们谈到如果他们真的带走了我们的父母，我们没关系，因为他们可以把我们和他们一起送回墨西哥。几乎每个人都在哭。
The new law is designed to work like this. Turn almost every encounter between a regular person and a government official into a checkpoint, and the illegals will leave on their own accord. That's self-deportation. Alabama's law, known as HB56, does this by enlisting every local and state police officer into the work of busting undocumented aliens.
这项新法律的设计初衷是这样的：将普通人和政府官员之间的几乎每一次接触都变成检查站，非法移民就会自行离开。这就是“自我驱逐”。阿拉巴马州的法律，被称为HB56，通过将每一位地方和州警察纳入打击无证外国人的工作中来实现这一点。
It also requires every state and local bureaucrat to first make sure you're legal before having any, quote, "transaction with a citizen." This includes everything from getting a hunting license to a mobile home registration sticker, to getting a death certificate. Undocumented kids can still attend public school. But administrators have to determine the immigration status of all new students.
它还要求每一位州和地方官僚在与公民进行任何所谓的“交易”之前，首先要确保你是合法的。这包括从获得狩猎执照到移动房屋登记贴纸，再到获得死亡证明的方方面面。无证儿童仍然可以上公立学校，但管理人员必须确定所有新学生的移民身份。
The law also makes it a crime for any citizen to knowingly hire or even help an undocumented worker in any way. The Home Builders Association of Alabama, the US Chamber of Commerce, the Alabama Farmers Federation, and other local business groups came out against the law, because it created heaps of new paperwork and made the state look like a bad place to invest.
该法律还规定，任何公民明知而雇佣或以任何方式帮助无证工人都构成犯罪。阿拉巴马州房屋建筑商协会、美国商会、阿拉巴马州农场主联合会和其他地方商业团体都反对这项法律，因为它制造了大量的新文书工作，并使该州看起来是个不适合投资的地方。
This bill was so far-reaching and so much unintended consequences out of it that continues to surface.
这项法案影响深远，并且从中产生了许多不断浮出水面的意想不到的后果。
This is Gerald Dial, the Republican whip in the state Senate, who helped pass the new law and now regrets it. He worries that new businesses are going to stay away.
这是杰拉德·戴尔，州参议院的共和党党鞭，他协助通过了这项新法律，现在却感到后悔。他担心新企业会望而却步。
I understand economic recruiting. And I say often that economic recruiting is more ruthless than quarterback recruiting for colleges. They'll use anything against you. And other states will begin to say, hey, you don't want to go to Alabama now.
我了解经济招商。我经常说，经济招商比大学橄榄球四分卫的招募还要冷酷。他们会利用任何事情来反对你。其他州会开始说，嘿，你现在不想去阿拉巴马州了。
If we're teetering out there, it's us and another, and everything's pretty even, we're probably going to lose those people. We won't know about it. It won't be a big red flag-- hey, we didn't go to Alabama. We're going to go to Arkansas, or we're going to go to South Carolina because of this. But those things are going to impact on people. And that's probably the most detrimental part of the whole bill.
如果我们处于摇摆不定的位置，对手和我们势均力敌，我们很可能会失去那些人。我们不会知道。这不会是一个巨大的红旗——嘿，我们不去阿拉巴马州了。我们会去阿肯色州，或者我们会因为这个去南卡罗来纳州。但这些事情会影响到人们。这可能是整个法案中最有害的部分。
The guy who runs Alabama's retirement system, David Bronner, declared in November that the new law was already chilling foreign investment. An $80 million Birmingham office tower, planned by a Spanish mega-bank, BBVA Group, had been scrapped. And the Chinese backers of a new copper plant in Thomasville were having second thoughts, Bronner said.
运营阿拉巴马州退休系统的戴维·布朗纳在11月宣布，这项新法律已经冷却了外国投资。西班牙巨型银行BBVA集团计划在伯明翰建设的一座8000万美元的办公大楼已被取消。布朗纳说，托马斯维尔一家新铜厂的中国支持者也产生了动摇。
Nine days later, the morning I arrived in Birmingham, the six-column headline screaming across the front page of the paper was, "Mercedes manager arrested under immigration law." The first newsworthy bust of this law was not a tractor-trailer filled with Mexican workers, but a German executive named Detlev Hager, who was seized and detained for not having the proper papers. It was the talk of the town all day. The St. Louis Post-Dispatch later published an editorial poking fun at Alabama for its southern inhospitality and invited Mercedes to move its plant to Missouri. "We are the Show-Me State," it said, "not the 'Show me your papers' state."
九天后，我到达伯明翰的早晨，报纸头版上用六列大标题尖叫着：“梅赛德斯经理根据移民法被捕”。这项法律第一个有新闻价值的逮捕行动不是装满墨西哥工人的拖挂卡车，而是一位名叫德特勒夫·哈格的德国高管，他因没有适当的文件而被扣留。那天全城都在议论纷纷。《圣路易斯邮报》后来发表了一篇社论，嘲笑阿拉巴马州的南方冷遇，并邀请梅赛德斯将其工厂搬到密苏里州。“我们是‘密苏里州’（Show-Me State，意为眼见为实州），”它说，“而不是‘给我看你的证件’州。”
A week later, another auto executive was stopped at a police checkpoint, this one from Honda. He was carrying an international driver's license, a passport, and a work permit. But it wasn't enough. The governor, Robert Bentley, freaked out. He held a press conference to let foreign executives know that they were still welcome in Alabama. "People just need to calm down," he said. "Everything's going to be OK."
一周后，另一位汽车高管在警察检查站被拦截，这次是本田公司的。他随身携带了国际驾照、护照和工作许可证，但这还不够。州长罗伯特·本特利吓坏了。他召开新闻发布会，让外国高管知道他们仍然受到阿拉巴马州的欢迎。“人们只需要冷静下来，”他说，“一切都会好起来的。”
I spoke with Steven Anderson, the police chief in Tuscaloosa, whose officer stopped the Mercedes executive. I figured he might be defensive about the arrest, considering it made national news and embarrassed the governor. But from his point of view, the situation was straightforward.
我与塔斯卡卢萨的警察局长史蒂文·安德森谈过，他的警官拦截了那位梅赛德斯高管。我以为他对逮捕行动会采取防御态度，考虑到这上了全国新闻并让州长感到尴尬。但从他的角度来看，情况很简单。
Officer made a traffic stop on a vehicle because it did not have a license plate displayed on the vehicle. The officer subsequently, under 32-6-9, was required to take that individual into custody.
警官对一辆车辆进行了交通拦截，因为它没有显示车牌。根据32-6-9条款，警官随后被要求将该个人拘留。
If those same circumstances were to happen this afternoon, would the executive be brought before a magistrate again? I mean, is that the process now?
如果今天下午发生同样的情况，这位高管还会被再次带到地方法官面前吗？我的意思是，这是现在的程序吗？
Yes. If the situation were to arise again, we would handle it just as we handled it.
是的。如果再次出现这种情况，我们会像处理上次一样处理它。
Back before the law, the officer could have issued a quick citation to the German executive on the side of the road.
在法律出台之前，警官本可以在路边向这位德国高管开出一张简易传票。
And be done with it in about a 15- to 20-minute traffic stop.
在15到20分钟的交通拦截中就完成了。
Versus?
相比之下呢？
Versus having to spend two or three hours with an individual while we determine whether they're here legally or not.
相比之下，我们要花两三个小时处理一个人，同时确定他们是否合法居留。
Chief Anderson tells me flat-out, he thinks this is a waste of resources, something his officers shouldn't be doing. But they have no choice, because the new law makes immigration a primary mission for police. Legislators put language into the law that allows any citizen to sue the police if they are caught not enforcing the immigration provision.
安德森局长直截了当地告诉我，他认为这是一种资源浪费，是他的警员不应该做的事情。但他们别无选择，因为新法律将移民执法变成了警察的首要任务。立法者在法律中加入了条款，允许任何公民在警察不执行移民规定时起诉他们。
To me, that just screamed of the fact that they understood that they had to have some type of sanctions out there to hold law enforcement's feet to the fire on this, because we wouldn't make this a priority if they didn't.
对我来说，这简直是在尖叫着一个事实，那就是他们明白必须有某种制裁措施来强迫执法部门执行这一点，因为如果他们不这样做，我们就不会把这当作优先事项。
And why wouldn't they make it a priority? Because there's actual crime in Tuscaloosa.
为什么他们不把它作为优先事项？因为塔斯卡卢萨确实存在真正的犯罪。
And I'll tell you what. The Hispanic population was not the population in our community that was committing those crimes. So immigration was not a problem for our police department. It was not in my top 10, maybe not even in my top 20, of concerns that I had for the city of Tuscaloosa.
我可以告诉你。拉美裔群体并不是我们社区中犯下那些罪行的人群。因此，移民问题对我们的警察部门来说不是一个问题。在我对塔斯卡卢萨市的担忧中，它甚至排不进前十，也许连前二十都排不进。
Not in the top 20 for many reasons. But here's one. There just aren't that many immigrants in Alabama. It's not like Arizona, where a third of the state is Latino. In Alabama, the number is less than 4%. And yet, rooting out illegal immigrants is now a priority across the state.
排不进前二十的原因有很多。但这里有一个：阿拉巴马州并没有那么多移民。它不像亚利桑那州，那里三分之一的人口是拉美裔。在阿拉巴马州，这一数字不到4%。然而，根除非法移民现在却成了全州的首要任务。
The law is so comprehensive that some officials seem to be overreaching, just to be on the safe side. An attorney told me about one guy being denied a jailhouse phone call, since use of the phone was considered a business transaction, and about a victim of domestic violence who was told by a judge that if she wanted a protective order, she might open herself up for deportation.
法律如此全面，以至于一些官员似乎为了保险起见而越权。一位律师告诉我，有人被拒绝拨打监狱电话，因为使用电话被视为商业交易；还有一位家庭暴力的受害者被法官告知，如果她想要保护令，她可能会让自己面临被驱逐的风险。
But what I found most surprising was that amid the chaos, regular Alabamians, here and there, were taking the law to heart, pursuing ad hoc immigration justice on their own. I met a young Costa Rican woman named Carolina who long ago overstayed her visa. She told me about a recent time at a grocery store checkout. She and her husband tried to pay for their food with a credit card and valid ID. The cashier refused them, saying they'd first have to show that they were here legally.
但我发现最令人惊讶的是，在混乱之中，普通的阿拉巴马人在这里和那里将法律铭记在心，独自寻求临时的移民正义。我遇到了一位名叫卡罗琳娜的年轻哥斯达黎加女性，她很久以前就签证逾期了。她告诉我最近在杂货店结账时发生的事。她和丈夫试图用信用卡和有效身份证件支付食品费用。收银员拒绝了他们，说他们必须先证明他们是合法居留。
I swear, they don't want to sell us the groceries.
我发誓，他们不想卖给我们杂货。
Carolina had just had a birthday when we met. And her mother back home had wired her some money to buy a gift, a money gram she could pick up at Walmart, not a government office, but a private business. So no problem. She'd done this many, many times in the nearly seven years she's lived in Alabama. Before the law, all she had to do was show ID and type in the secret PIN number her mother had sent her. But this time--
卡罗琳娜见到我们时刚过完生日。在家乡的母亲给她汇了一些钱买礼物，这是一种她可以在沃尔玛领取的汇款，这不是政府办公室，而是一家私人企业。所以没问题。在她居住在阿拉巴马州的近七年里，她做过很多次。法律出台前，她只需要出示身份证并输入母亲寄给她的秘密密码。但这一次——
They did not give me the money. They just refused to give me the money, because I cannot prove to the girl that I was legal. And I don't know why I have to prove her that.
他们没有给我钱。他们拒绝给我钱，因为我无法向那个女孩证明我是合法的。我不知道我为什么要向她证明。
Again, this is not part of the law.
同样，这并不是法律的一部分。
So I tried a lot with her. I was dealing with her for about 15 minutes. But she says no. So I went already to three different Walmarts. And I don't have my money yet.
所以我跟她争取了很多。我跟她交涉了大约15分钟。但她说不。所以我已经去了三家不同的沃尔玛。但我还是没拿到钱。
When we asked Walmart about this, a spokesperson said their procedures for getting a money gram are the same at every store nationwide and don't require proof of citizenship. Another provision of the law makes any contract with an undocumented alien unenforceable in court. Some people are using it to mess with illegal immigrants. Mary Bauer is a lawyer with the Southern Poverty Law Center.
当我们问及沃尔玛时，一位发言人表示，他们在全国所有商店领取汇款的程序都是一样的，不需要公民身份证明。法律的另一项规定使与无证外国人的任何合同在法庭上无法执行。一些人利用这一点来对付非法移民。玛丽·鲍尔是南方贫困法律中心的一名律师。
Certainly, people have been told that they're not going to be able to rent housing anymore. That's something that's been very common. Some workers have been told that they're not going to get paid for the work they've already done, because that would be an illegal contract.
当然，人们被告知他们将无法再租房。这是非常普遍的事情。一些工人被告知他们不会得到已经完成工作的报酬，因为那将是一份非法合同。
Before the law, undocumented people like Carolina expected certain bureaucratic inconveniences. She couldn't get a water bill in her own name. And sure, she had to be careful in certain situations. She worried what would happen if she were pulled over by a traffic cop.
在法律出台之前，像卡罗琳娜这样的无证人员预料到了某些官僚主义的麻烦。她不能以自己的名义支付水费。当然，她在某些情况下必须小心。她担心如果被交警拦截会发生什么。
But by and large, life was predictable. It wasn't scary. The intention of the law is to take all that away, to make life uncomfortable. And it's working. Now Carolina told me that before she drives anywhere in a car, she says a prayer.
但总的来说，生活是可预测的。并不吓人。法律的目的是夺走这一切，让生活变得不舒服。而且它正在奏效。现在卡罗琳娜告诉我，在她开车去任何地方之前，她都会祈祷。
She has appointed a legal guardian, an American, for her three-year-old son, in case she disappears into an immigration holding cell. At least she'll know that her son won't wind up in foster care. And recently, she made a decision. Her son loves preschool. He's a smart kid. And he's got a lot of friends there. But getting caught on the road now on the drive back and forth to school is too risky.
她为三岁的儿子指定了一名美国监护人，以防她消失在移民拘留室中。至少她会知道她的儿子不会最终进入寄养系统。最近，她做出了一个决定。她的儿子喜欢学前班。他是个聪明的孩子，在那里有很多朋友。但现在往返学校的路上被拦截太冒险了。
And actually, this is the last month that my son is going to school, because he's not safe with me to take him to school. And he's going to be safe in here, at home.
实际上，这是我儿子上学的最后一个月了，因为带他去上学，他跟我在一起不安全。他待在家里会更安全。
For a lot of Latinos who've decided to stay in Alabama, life has become about hunkering down, waiting and seeing. I went to a mobile home park where a lot of undocumented immigrants live, and spent a day with a mother named Gabriella. Like Carolina, she's afraid to drive now. But she's taken it one step further. She's quit her job and almost never goes out.
对于许多决定留在阿拉巴马州的拉美裔人来说，生活变成了缩在家里，静观其变。我去了许多无证移民居住的移动房屋公园，和一位名叫加布里埃拉的母亲度过了一天。像卡罗琳娜一样，她现在不敢开车。但她更进一步，辞掉了工作，几乎从不出门。
And I had to be here, hide in my own home, because I need to stay here for my children when they come back from the school.
我不得不待在这里，躲在自己的家里，因为我需要在孩子们放学回来时守着他们。
Folks like Gabriella have another strategy, too-- try not to encounter white people at all. They only shop at Hispanic markets. Carolina told me that when she does go to a regular grocery store now, she wanders up and down the cashier area, hoping to catch a subtle smile before getting into a checkout line.
像加布里埃拉这样的人还有另一个策略——尽量根本不与白人接触。他们只在拉美裔市场购物。卡罗琳娜告诉我，现在当她去普通的杂货店时，她会在收银区走来走去，希望能捕捉到一个细微的微笑，然后再进入结账队列。
Another mobile homeowner told me he'd heard of a friendly clerk in a neighboring town who would renew mobile home licenses without asking too many questions. Others said they've created an underground railroad of information about sympathetic folks and make contact with faith groups that defiantly provide workers rides to their jobs. Gabriella said that the new attitude has permeated every aspect of her life, every aspect.
另一位移动房屋的主人告诉我，他听说邻近小镇有一位友好的办事员会续签移动房屋许可证，而不会问太多问题。其他人说，他们建立了一个关于同情人士的地下信息网络，并与那些反抗地为工人提供工作乘车的宗教团体建立联系。加布里埃拉说，这种新态度已经渗透到她生活的每一个方面，每一个方面。
Even in the church.
即使在教堂里。
Really?
真的吗？
Yes, because even in the church, you find people that say, well, we are in God's house. And then they don't want to talk at you. And they don't want to give the peace to you. That is so sad.
是的，因为即使在教堂里，你也会发现有人说，嗯，我们是在上帝的房子里。然后他们不想和你说话。他们不想把平安交给你。这太可悲了。
So in your church, you have the passing of the peace, that part of the service? And so in your church, when they do that, what normally happens? You turn and shake hands with people?
所以在你们的教堂里，有传递平安的仪式，那是仪式的一部分？那么在你们的教堂里，当他们这样做时，通常会发生什么？你转身和人们握手吗？
Yes. They shake hands and everything. But now I found some people that say, I don't want to do peace with you.
是的。他们握手什么的。但现在我发现有些人说，我不想和你交换平安。
Every Latino person, legal or illegal, whom I spoke to noted at some point that there's just something hateful in the air now. Before the law, they felt accepted. They had American friends. They didn't feel out of place.
我交谈过的每一位拉美裔人，无论是合法的还是非法的，都在某种程度上指出，现在空气中弥漫着一种仇恨的东西。法律出台前，他们感到被接纳。他们有美国朋友。他们不觉得格格不入。
Now when they go to a store, every single one of them told me they feel that people are looking at them weirdly, like, what are you still doing here? When the law changed to make them less welcome, they actually became less welcome, in a day-to-day, "passing you on the street" sort of way. School kids told me they're fighting off comments like, I'm glad you're all moving, we don't want you here, you take our jobs. At a pep rally, where Latinos were all sitting up front, kids started shouting, Mexicans move to the back. And most of them did.
现在当他们去商店时，他们每个人都告诉我，他们感到人们用奇怪的眼光看着他们，好像在说，你还待在这里干什么？当法律改变使得他们不受欢迎时，他们在日常生活中，在“街头擦肩而过”的过程中，实际上确实变得不受欢迎了。学龄儿童告诉我，他们在反抗类似这样的评论：“我很高兴你们都搬走了，我们不想要你们在这里，你们抢了我们的工作。”在一次加油集会上，拉美裔人都坐在前排，孩子们开始喊：“墨西哥人搬到后面去。”他们大多数人都照做了。
How many people have left your class?
有多少人离开了你的班级？
There's missing about at least five in each one of my classes.
我的每个班级至少缺席了五个人。
Are there friends of yours?
他们是你的朋友吗？
Yeah.
是的。
This is Stephanie. She was hanging out with Gabriella's daughter and some other kids in the back of Gabriella's trailer, playing video games while their parents held a prayer meeting in the other room, hoping for repeal of the new law. We talked about all the kids that had left her school since October.
这是斯蒂芬妮。她和加布里埃拉的女儿以及其他一些孩子在加布里埃拉的拖车后面玩电子游戏，而他们的父母在另一个房间举行祈祷会，希望废除这项新法律。我们谈到了自十月以来离开她学校的所有孩子。
It was really hard to let them go, mostly because they were girls. One of the names was Jessie. She was my best friend. But she had to leave because of the law. So what we did, we went to the movies before she left. And the day that she left, I went to the store and bought her a teddy bear. We started to cry.
让他们走真的很痛苦，主要是因为她们是女孩。其中一个名字叫杰西。她是我最好的朋友。但她必须离开，因为这项法律。所以我们做了什么呢？我们在她离开前去了电影院。在她离开的那天，我去了商店给她买了一只泰迪熊。我们开始哭。
When was that?
那是什么时候？
Two weeks ago.
两周前。
And where did she move to?
她搬到哪里去了？
She moved to Mexico.
她搬到墨西哥去了。
And what did she tell you about Mexico?
她跟你说了关于墨西哥的什么？
She said that it's funner than here. She said that she can move around. Her parents let her go out more, because they're not scared that immigration or something, that she can just be free, go out to the mall by herself, because here, we can't do that without getting in trouble or something.
她说那里比这里更有趣。她说她可以到处走动。她的父母让她出去更多，因为他们不害怕移民什么的，她可以自由自在地独自去商场，因为在这里，我们做不到那样，否则会惹上麻烦什么的。
Stephanie says that. But the adults, in fact, are terrified of Mexico. They read the papers, too, and hear of dead bodies found in playgrounds, revenge killings, random murders. If the new law brings more pressure on them, the grown-ups say, they might move to another state, but not to Mexico.
斯蒂芬妮这么说。但大人们实际上对墨西哥感到恐惧。他们也看报纸，听说操场上发现尸体、复仇杀人、随机谋杀。大人们说，如果新法律给他们带来更大的压力，他们可能会搬到另一个州，但不会去墨西哥。
Here's Gabriella again. A friend of hers did go back to Mexico just after the law passed.
再说说加布里埃拉。她的一个朋友在法律通过后确实回到了墨西哥。
And I even called her last week. She was crying, because she never thought Mexico was so scary. And she told me, I prefer to be there, waiting for the police to catch me. But here, I'm afraid. And they are going to kill my children or me.
我上周甚至给她打了电话。她在哭，因为她从没想过墨西哥这么可怕。她告诉我，我宁愿在那里等警察来抓我。但在这里，我害怕。他们会杀死我的孩子或我。
Besides the fear, Gabriella's like any mom. Her kids are Americans. They were born here. Their friends are all here. Alabama's their home. She doesn't want to uproot them or herself. We met in November, in her living room. Earlier this week, as I was finishing this story, I found out that Gabriella's husband was arrested and deported. She and her children have moved to Mexico.
除了恐惧，加布里埃拉就像任何母亲一样。她的孩子是美国人。他们出生在这里。他们的朋友都在这里。阿拉巴马州是他们的家。她不想把他们或自己连根拔起。我们是在11月在她的客厅里见面的。本周早些时候，当我完成这个故事时，我发现加布里埃拉的丈夫被捕并被驱逐出境了。她和她的孩子们已经搬到了墨西哥。
All these bills are designed for people to say, you know what, they're going to try to enforce the law here in this state. And maybe we need to move back to our home country. Or maybe we need to move to a state that has its arms wide open for illegal aliens.
所有这些法案都是为了让人们说，你知道吗，他们要在这个州强行执行法律。也许我们需要搬回我们的祖国。或者也许我们需要搬到一个张开双臂欢迎非法外国人的州。
Senator Scott Beason is the Republican leader in the state legislature. And he was the primary sponsor of the bill last year. As far as he's concerned, the law is working spectacularly well. In just three months, it's prompted massive self-deportation, roughly 75,000 people. And, Beason says, this has opened up jobs for American citizens, just like lawmakers hoped it would.
斯科特·比森参议员是州立法机构的共和党领袖。他是去年该法案的主要发起人。就他而言，法律执行得非常出色。仅仅三个月，它就促成了大规模的自我驱逐，大约75,000人。而且，比森说，这为美国公民提供了工作机会，正如立法者希望的那样。
Of course, it only went into effect October 1. We've already seen a tremendous drop in our unemployment numbers. In the month of October alone, while the country averaged a tenth of 1% drop, Alabama had five times that. And that's corrected seasonal numbers. So we're very proud of what the legislation has done already.
当然，它直到10月1日才生效。我们已经看到了失业人数的巨大下降。仅在10月份，当全国平均下降0.1%时，阿拉巴马州是其五倍。这是修正后的季节性数据。所以我们为这项立法已经取得的成就感到非常自豪。
Given those numbers, Beason has every right to be proud. He's saying Alabama shaved half a percentage point off the unemployment rolls in October, while the national average was a piddly one-tenth of 1%. And that's in a place that ranks among the lowest states in terms of illegal immigration. If Beason's right, then a quick solution to this unending recession and its high unemployment would be an anti-immigration bill like Alabama's in every state. Jobs, Beason told me, were the main reason he drafted this bill.
鉴于这些数字，比森有权感到自豪。他说，阿拉巴马州在10月份将失业率降低了0.5个百分点，而全国平均水平仅为微不足道的0.1%。而且这还是在一个在非法移民方面排名最低的州之一的地方。如果比森是对的，那么解决这种无休止的衰退及其高失业率的一个快速方案将是每个州都有一项像阿拉巴马州那样的反移民法案。比森告诉我，工作机会是他起草这项法案的主要原因。
I would probably say one of the most moving stories is, back in 2008, we had started the immigration commission. And we were in Huntsville, Alabama. And there was a woman who came up. I don't know her name. I'd never seen her before and never seen her again. My guess is she was in some sort of maid service, custodial service.
我可能会说最感人的故事之一是，早在2008年，我们启动了移民委员会。我们在阿拉巴马州的亨茨维尔。有一位妇女走了上来。我不知道她的名字。我以前从未见过她，以后也没再见过。我猜她是做某种女佣服务、保管服务的。
She came up to the table and said, Senator-- she was beginning to cry-- she said, I just want to let you know that in the job service I'm in, a lot of my competition has begun to hire people who aren't supposed to be here at all. They're here illegally. Because of that competition, I can't find work. I've lost my clients. And I have just paid my house payment on my credit card.
她走到桌子前说，参议员——她开始哭了——她说，我只是想让你知道，在我所从事的工作服务中，我的许多竞争对手已经开始雇佣那些根本不应该在这里的人。他们是非法居留的。因为那种竞争，我找不到工作。我失去了客户。我刚刚用信用卡支付了我的住房贷款。
When I tell that story today, it still breaks my heart. And I decided that was one of the main things. I've been interested in this issue. But this is the kind of thing that cannot be allowed. We were elected to stand up for that lady. And if I ever get a little deterred about what we're trying to do, I think about that lady's face, the story she told me. I've never talked to her again. And I hope that now that we've done something, that we've helped her.
今天讲那个故事时，它仍然让我心碎。我决定那是主要的事情之一。我一直对这个问题很感兴趣。但这是不能被允许的事情。我们被选出来为那位女士挺身而出。如果我对比森所做的事情有一点点动摇，我就会想起那位女士的脸，她告诉我的故事。我再也没有和她交谈过。我希望现在我们做了一些事情，我们已经帮助了她。
Whether he's helped her is unclear, because when it comes to the impressive unemployment numbers Beason cites, there's a catch. Other than Beason and his strongest supporters, I could not find anyone else who attributed the drop in unemployment to the new law.
他是否帮助了她尚不清楚，因为当谈到比森引用的令人印象深刻的失业数据时，有一个问题。除了比森和他最坚定的支持者外，我找不到任何其他人将失业率的下降归因于这项新法律。
The director of economic forecasting at the University of Alabama, Ahmad Ijaz, he didn't. In fact, he said that most of the job growth last year was in the automotive sector. You don't find many illegal workers in those Mercedes and Honda plants. He went on to say that the other area of growth this fall was retail, probably due to the seasonal Christmas bump. And Ijaz says there wasn't any job growth in sectors where Latinos typically work-- agriculture, poultry processing, and construction.
阿拉巴马大学经济预测主任艾哈迈德·伊贾兹没有。事实上，他说去年大部分就业增长是在汽车行业。你在那些梅赛德斯和本田工厂里找不到很多非法工人。他接着说，今年秋天增长的另一个领域是零售业，这可能是由于季节性的圣诞高峰。伊贾兹说，在拉美裔通常工作的领域——农业、家禽加工和建筑业——没有任何就业增长。
So how did immigration become the hottest political topic in a state with relatively few illegal immigrants? It wasn't much of an issue at all in Alabama until 2010, when Beason and his fellow Republicans put it on the agenda in a big way way. They campaigned on a set of promises they called "the Republican handshake," five pledges to voters, including combating illegal immigration.
那么，在一个非法移民相对较少的州，移民是如何成为最热门的政治话题的？直到2010年，这在阿拉巴马州根本不是一个大问题，当时比森和他的共和党同僚将其以大张旗鼓的方式列入议程。他们带着一系列他们称之为“共和党握手”的承诺进行竞选，对选民做出五项承诺，包括打击非法移民。
The Alabama legislature has been dominated by Democrats since the Civil War. But the handshake worked. Republicans gained super majorities in both chambers of Alabama's legislature. They essentially could pass anything they wanted. And they had a mandate from the people. Democrats say the people had little to do with it.
自内战以来，阿拉巴马州议会一直由民主党主导。但“握手”奏效了。共和党人在阿拉巴马州议会的两个议院都获得了绝对多数。他们基本上可以通过他们想要的任何东西。他们得到了人民的授权。民主党人说，这与人民关系不大。
I did not once hear about immigration when I was on the campaign trail. Now, keep in mind I live in an urban district. But it seemed to me to be more of a political issue than a practical issue.
我在竞选活动中一次也没听说过移民问题。现在，请记住我住在城市选区。但对我来说，这似乎更多是一个政治问题，而不是一个实际问题。
Joe Hubbard is a conservative Democrat for Montgomery. He was also elected in 2010. He says that the immigration issue represents a fundamental change in the way Alabama politicians run for state office, one that's been in the works for years.
乔·哈伯德是蒙哥马利的一位保守派民主党人。他也是在2010年当选的。他说，移民问题代表了阿拉巴马州政客竞选州职位方式的根本变化，这种变化已经酝酿多年。
In the past decade or so, before 2010, your state legislator was as local a politician as you got. He was the guy that you talked to about schools. He was the guy that you talked to about funding for that road project you need. And so the legislature was, in essence, a very local race.
在过去十年左右，在2010年之前，你的州议员是你所能接触到的最基层的政客。他是你谈论学校的人。他是你谈论你需要的那条道路项目的资金的人。所以立法机关本质上是一场非常地方性的竞选。
I think from 2004 to 2006, and ultimately in 2010, you saw efforts by the Alabama Republican Party to nationalize local elections and to talk about what's going on in DC, the congressional Democrats, Nancy Pelosi, on and on. I think there was polling that showed immigration, which heretofore has been a national issue, could make for good state political fodder.
我认为从2004年到2006年，最终在2010年，你看到了阿拉巴马州共和党为将地方选举全国化所做的努力，以及谈论华盛顿正在发生的事情，国会民主党人，南希·佩洛西等等。我认为有民意调查显示，移民问题——迄今为止一直是全国性的问题——可以成为很好的州级政治素材。
And when it came to actually writing the immigration bill, Hubbard says, the Alabama Republicans seemed to listen not so much to local voters, but to strategists in the National Republican Party.
当真正起草移民法案时，哈伯德说，阿拉巴马州的共和党人似乎不是在听地方选民的意见，而是在听国家共和党战略家的意见。
And I think Alabama, perhaps, has become a state where the National Party could try out some legislative experiments to see how they'd work in other states. I'm not sure. But that appears to be the case on immigration.
我认为阿拉巴马州可能已经成为一个国家党可以尝试一些立法实验的地方，看看它们在其他州如何运作。我不确定。但移民问题似乎就是这种情况。
And I know for a fact that an attorney from the Midwest actually drafted the legislation that the state legislature passed. The bill that came out of conference committee was not drafted by any Alabama legislator. It was drafted by an attorney. And his name escapes me right now.
而且我确定，实际上是一位来自中西部的律师起草了州议会通过的立法。从会议委员会出来的法案不是由任何阿拉巴马州立法者起草的。它是由一位律师起草的。他的名字我现在想不起来了。
My name is Kris Kobach. And I'm Secretary of State of the state of Kansas.
我的名字是克里斯·科巴赫。我是堪萨斯州的州务卿。
And he's the mastermind of attrition through enforcement. You might not have heard of him, but he's an up-and-coming Republican star. He was campaigning with Mitt Romney in South Carolina all last week. He's helped write different immigration bills in cities and states all over the country-- Pennsylvania, Texas, Missouri, Nebraska, Utah. And he wrote Arizona's law.
他是“通过执法实现减员”的主谋。你可能没听说过他，但他是一位冉冉升起的共和党明星。上周他一直在南卡罗来纳州为米特·罗姆尼竞选。他帮助起草了全国各地的不同移民法案——宾夕法尼亚州、德克萨斯州、密苏里州、内布拉斯加州、犹他州。他起草了亚利桑那州的法律。
So some folks, on the weekends, they go into their garage and fiddle with their car. You go into your garage and fiddle with immigration law.
所以有些人周末去车库里摆弄他们的车。你去车库里摆弄移民法。
Yeah. People do with their spare time what they feel fulfilled in. And so some people golf. Some people work on their car in the garage. I go into my home office and start typing away on the computer and trying to help states do what they can to restore the rule of law.
是的。人们用他们感到充实的方式度过业余时间。有些人打高尔夫球。有些人去车库里修车。我走进我的家庭办公室，开始在电脑上打字，试图帮助各州尽其所能恢复法治。
And if you're starting a new movement, Kris Kobach is who you want to have as your spokesman-- Harvard undergrad, master's degree from Oxford, Yale law. He's young. He has three adorable children. He is ruggedly handsome in a "TV superhero, rip off his shirt" sort of way. And in the final days, as the Alabama immigration bill came close to a final vote, the lawmakers wanted his help. Even though Kobach already had plans, he's not the kind of man to turn his back on legislators in distress.
如果你要开启一场新运动，克里斯·科巴赫就是你想要的发言人——哈佛本科生，牛津硕士，耶鲁法学院。他很年轻。他有三个可爱的孩子。他有着“电视超级英雄，撕掉衬衫”那样的粗犷帅气。在阿拉巴马州移民法案接近最终投票的最后几天，立法者想要他的帮助。尽管科巴赫已经有了计划，但他不是那种会对陷入困境的立法者背过身去的人。
I had already scheduled a turkey hunt and was going to be in Gardner, Kansas, looking to call in and shoot a tom turkey, and realized that if I wanted to get this work done, I'd have to do it while in the turkey blind or just give up on the hunting. So I got in the blind, took my laptop computer, took my shotgun, and got all set up and had a good, fully charged battery, and just started working on the final amendments to the bill. And fortunately I did that, because the turkey didn't show up that day. So I had something else to do. Maybe it was the clicking on the keyboard that scared them away.
我已经计划好去火鸡狩猎，本来要在堪萨斯州加德纳寻找并射杀一只雄火鸡，然后意识到如果我想完成这项工作，我就得在火鸡掩体里做，或者放弃狩猎。所以我进了掩体，带上笔记本电脑，带上猎枪，做好了一切准备，电池电量充足，就开始起草法案的最终修正案。幸运的是我那样做了，因为那天火鸡没出现。所以我还有别的事情可做。也许是键盘的敲击声把它们吓跑了。
For Kobach, the passage of HB56 was the culmination of years of work. He'd been drafting and trying out different laws in other places, seeing if they'd hold up in court, revising, trying them again. Then a few years ago, he met Senator Beason at a conservative conference. They collaborated on an anti-illegal immigration bill that went nowhere.
对科巴赫来说，HB56的通过是他多年工作的结晶。他一直在起草并尝试在其他地方实施不同的法律，看看它们能否在法庭上站得住脚，修订，再试一次。几年前，他在一次保守派会议上遇到了比森参议员。他们合作制定了一项反非法移民法案，但无疾而终。
Then in 2010, with new super majorities in the Alabama legislature, they could try everything on their immigration wish list, even things Republicans didn't get into the Arizona law, that immigration data would be collected on all entering schoolchildren, that every business transaction with the state would require a birth certificate. After much of Alabama's bill held up in court, Kobach felt he'd finally had a template for other states to adopt. Kobach has been working on illegal immigration since 2001. His big insight came right after 9/11, when he was working for the Justice Department.
然后在2010年，随着阿拉巴马州议会中新的绝对多数，他们可以尝试他们移民愿望清单上的所有事情，即使是共和党人没有在亚利桑那州法律中加入的事情：所有入学学童的移民数据都将被收集，与州的每一项商业交易都需要出生证明。在阿拉巴马州的法案大部分在法庭上站稳脚跟后，科巴赫觉得他终于有了一个供其他州采用的模板。科巴赫自2001年以来一直致力于非法移民问题。他的重大洞察是在9/11之后产生的，当时他在司法部工作。
It was an a-ha moment when I realized that five of the 19 hijackers were in the country illegally. Four of those five had traffic violations while they were illegally in the country. And if the police officer had had that information at his fingertips, he could have made an arrest.
当意识到19名劫机者中有5人非法居留时，那是一个“啊哈”时刻。那五人中有四人在非法居留期间有交通违规记录。如果警察手头有这些信息，他本可以进行逮捕。
But cops don't check for immigration status. Immigration agents do. The problem was, there were only a few thousand of them. Kobach realized what we need is what war planners call a force multiplier. What if we enlisted the more than 700,000 state and local law enforcement officers across the country into the fight against illegal immigration?
但警察不检查移民身份。移民代理人会检查。问题是，他们只有几千人。科巴赫意识到我们需要的是战争策划者所说的“武力倍增器”。如果我们招募全国70多万州和地方执法人员加入打击非法移民的战斗会怎样？
The simplicity of Kobach's argument is what's so appealing. He isn't creating new policy at all. He's simply empowering states to enforce what is already in the federal statutes.
科巴赫论点的简单性是它如此吸引人的原因。他根本没有制定新的政策。他只是授权各州执行联邦法规中已经存在的内容。
And from the alien's perspective, it's better, too. He can depart the United States on his own, freely, without ever being in custody. And so there's more liberty for him. And there's less cost for the United States.
从外国人的角度来看，这也更好。他可以自由地离开美国，不必被拘留。因此，对他来说有更多的自由。而对美国来说成本更低。
There's less cost, because if someone self-deports, there's no arrest. There's no detention or immigration hearing. Attrition through enforcement sounds so rational, so clean, when Kobach explains it, like it'll happen automatically. You don't have to do much. They'll just go.
成本更低，因为如果有人自我驱逐，就没有逮捕，没有拘留或移民听证。“通过执法实现减员”听起来很理性，很干净，当科巴赫解释它时，就像它会自动发生一样。你不需要做什么。他们就会走。
But of course, the reality of self-deportation is much messier than that. You're threatening to separate parents and kids, drive them from their homes. It's completely primal, the things that terrify us most. And that is the actual plan, to scare them.
但当然，自我驱逐的现实要混乱得多。你在威胁要分离父母和孩子，把他们赶出家园。这是最原始的，最让我们感到恐惧的事情。这就是实际计划，去吓唬他们。
I asked Kobach, point by point, about the unintended consequences of the Alabama bill. He disputed everything. Did it hurt business? Did it create chaos in the schools? All overstated, he said. Finally, I asked him if it unearthed long-sequestered racial attitudes aimed at Latinos.
我逐点询问了科巴赫关于阿拉巴马州法案意想不到的后果。他反驳了一切。它损害了商业吗？它在学校造成混乱了吗？他说，都夸大了。最后，我问他，这是否挖掘出了长期被隔离的针对拉美裔的种族态度。
I think it's really an argument of last resort. And that is, well, if you start enforcing immigration laws more aggressively, that's going to become a racially charged issue. And my answer is, no, it's not. I don't buy it. And frankly, that hasn't happened.
我认为这真的是最后的手段。那就是，如果你开始更积极地执行移民法，那将成为一个种族议题。而我的回答是，不，它不是。我不买账。坦率地说，这并没有发生。
Well, you must know that there are people in Alabama who are saying unholy things as a result of this law, no?
好吧，你一定知道阿拉巴马州有些人因为这项法律正在说邪恶的话，不是吗？
Well, I don't think it's fair to say as a result of the law. You can't legislate what is in people's hearts. And if people have those twisted ideas of the world and have those ill feelings toward people who have a different skin color, I don't think you can say that the law has caused that. And I don't think you can say that the law can ultimately stop that. I would also say that Alabama's reputation has also increased around the country, too. There are many legislators in other states that are saying, they've really done something great.
好吧，我不认为说是法律的结果是公平的。你不能立法规定人们心里想什么。如果人们有那种扭曲的世界观，对不同肤色的人有那些恶念，我不认为你能说法律造成了这一点。我也不认为你能说法律最终能阻止这一点。我还想说，阿拉巴马州在全国的声誉也提高了。其他州的许多立法者都在说，他们真的做了一件伟大的事情。
Do you think there have been any unintended consequences from this bill?
你认为这项法案有什么意想不到的后果吗？
No, not really. I mean, there have been some minor misinterpretations by one or two local officials of how they read the language. But that's inevitable with any state law.
没有，真的没有。我的意思是，一两个地方官员对他们如何解读语言有一些小的误解。但这对任何州法律来说都是不可避免的。
Which brings us back to State Senator Gerald Dial, the Republican whip you heard earlier, who's worried about scaring away business. He's leading a campaign to, as he puts it, "tweak the law," in all sorts of ways. Here's a big one. He wants to get rid of this idea that any attempt to help people who might be illegal is itself illegal. That bothers him enormously. He's a devout Christian, so he wants to insert a Good Samaritan provision to protect good, charitable folks who are just practicing their faith.
这让我们回到了州参议员杰拉德·戴尔，也就是你之前听到的担心吓跑商业的共和党党鞭。他正在领导一场他所谓的“调整法律”的运动，以各种方式。这是一个大动作。他想摆脱那种认为任何帮助可能是非法移民的人的行为本身就是非法的想法。这让他非常困扰。他是一位虔诚的基督徒，所以他想加入一个“好撒玛利亚人”条款，以保护那些只是在践行信仰的善良慈善人士。
I had a man who runs a soup kitchen, feeds people just off the street, call me and said, that's just terrible, because I feed people. And I don't stop the door and say, are you here illegally or legal? I feed you because you're hungry. And so that's a compassionate thing. And that's the Christian thing to do. And we're going to put that part into the bill also.
我有一个经营汤厨房的人，为街上的人提供食物，他打电话给我说，这太可怕了，因为我给人们喂食。我不会停在门口说，你是非法还是合法居留的？我给你喂食是因为你饿了。所以这是一种同情心。这是基督徒的做法。我们也要把那部分放入法案中。
OK. So once you've amended the bill, do you think Jesus would vote for the bill?
好的。那么一旦你修改了法案，你认为耶稣会投票支持该法案吗？
Gosh, you've asked me a tough question. I would hope that he would understand. I would say that, would he vote for the bill? Probably not. Probably not. If you just laid it all the way down, probably not.
天哪，你问了我一个难题。我希望他能理解。我想说，他会投票支持该法案吗？可能不会。可能不会。如果你真的把一切都摊开来说，可能不会。
Don't get Dial wrong. He still favors a strong law to encourage self-deportation. But he thinks the law that passed last session, the rush and reach of it, the stuff that got inserted last minute, and the stuff he was told that would be included but wasn't, is hurting the state.
别误解戴尔。他仍然赞成强有力的法律来鼓励自我驱逐。但他认为上一届会议通过的法律，其仓促和范围，最后一刻插入的东西，以及被告知会包含但实际上没有包含的东西，正在伤害这个州。
I would not have voted for the bill had I understood the unintended consequences. There are others who would not have also. But you were locked into position, where you either vote for this, or you vote against it. And therefore, you're encouraging illegals.
如果我理解意想不到的后果，我就不会投票支持该法案。还有其他人也不会。但你被锁定在一个位置，要么投票支持，要么投票反对。因此，你是在鼓励非法移民。
So you're in a catch-22 as far as that goes. So to show that we were not illegals, we had to vote for the bill. But today, after hearing our constituents talk and after looking at the problem, we're going to try to fix some of those problems.
所以你在那方面陷入了僵局。为了证明我们不是非法移民，我们不得不投票支持该法案。但今天，在听取了选民的谈话并研究了问题之后，我们将尝试解决其中的一些问题。
There is a bill, there is a proposed total repeal of HB56. If it just came down to keeping things the way they are or voting for total repeal, how would you vote?
有一项法案，有一个提议完全废除HB56。如果只是归结为保持原样或投票完全废除，你会怎么投？
Well, I would probably vote for the repeal. But the repeal bill's not going to get before us.
好吧，我可能会投票支持废除。但废除法案不会摆在我们面前。
I asked Joe Hubbard, the Montgomery democrat, what he thought the chances were for repeal.
我问蒙哥马利民主党人乔·哈伯德，他认为废除的机会有多大。
Zero.
零。
Republicans have been pounding this issue for too long to backtrack now. Besides, Hubbard says, they don't need to.
共和党人在这个问题上投入了太长时间，现在已经无法回头了。此外，哈伯德说，他们不需要回头。
The politics of this bill are very good for the Republicans, I think. A Republican operative told me the other day that this bill's polling very high in popularity in Alabama. Expect to see this same bill, HB56-- it's already been in South Carolina passed-- expect to see it in many other Republican-controlled legislatures.
我认为这项法案的政治对共和党人来说非常有利。一位共和党特工前几天告诉我，这项法案在阿拉巴马州的民意调查中非常受欢迎。期待看到同样的法案，HB56——它已经在南卡罗来纳州通过了——期待在许多其他共和党控制的立法机构中看到它。
Last week, Alabama's law made a national debut of sorts. Kris Kobach endorsed Mitt Romney. And the two spent time traveling South Carolina together, talking to voters about their new third way to reform immigration. Then this week, Romney introduced the idea during a Republican debate.
上周，阿拉巴马州的法律在某种程度上进行了全国首秀。克里斯·科巴赫支持了米特·罗姆尼。两人上周一起在南卡罗来纳州旅行，与选民谈论他们新的第三种移民改革方式。然后本周，罗姆尼在共和党辩论中提出了这个想法。
Well, the answer is self-deportation, which is people decide that they could do better by going home, because they can't find work here, because they don't have legal documentation to allow them to work here.
好吧，答案是自我驱逐，即人们决定回国会做得更好，因为他们在这里找不到工作，因为他们没有合法的文档允许他们在这里工作。
Isn't that we have now? If somebody doesn't feel they have the opportunity in America, they can go back anytime they want to.
那不是我们现在拥有的吗？如果有人觉得在美国没有机会，他们随时可以回去。
Yes, we'd have a card that indicates who's here legally. And if people--
是的，我们会有一张卡，表明谁在这里合法居留。如果人们——
You can hear the audience laughing a little. And Romney struggles a bit to explain what he means. It sounds preposterous. Why would anyone leave if they didn't have to? Within days, Newt Gingrich was slapping Romney around on the issue. Quote, "For Romney to believe that somebody's grandmother is going to be so cut off that she's going to self-deport, I mean, this is an Obama-level fantasy."
你可以听到观众在笑。罗姆尼努力解释他的意思。这听起来荒谬。如果不是不得已，谁会离开呢？几天之内，纽特·金里奇就在这个问题上抨击罗姆尼。引用：“对于罗姆尼来说，相信某个人的祖母会如此被孤立以至于她会自我驱逐，我的意思是，这简直是奥巴马级别的幻想。”
By Thursday's debate, Romney had his pitch down better, and Gingrich didn't come off as well. Even Rick Santorum chimed in. He was for self-deportation, too.
到周四的辩论时，罗姆尼的论调好多了，金里奇表现得也不怎么样。连里克·桑托勒姆也插嘴了。他也支持自我驱逐。
By the time the Republicans decide their nominee, voters will come to know the meaning of this word, and it will no doubt be part of the electoral shorthand. Repeal health care. Cut taxes. Reform Medicare. Self-deportation.
当共和党人决定他们的提名人时，选民将了解这个词的含义，毫无疑问它将成为选举简写的一部分。废除医疗保健。减税。改革医疗保险。自我驱逐。
Jack Hitt. He's got a new book coming out this spring, called Bunch of Amateurs. The Alabama legislature is going back into session February 7. They're planning to take up possible changes to the immigration law. Meanwhile, parts of the law have been suspended by the courts. Some provisions will come before the United States Supreme Court this term when it considers the constitutionality of the Arizona immigration law.
杰克·希特。他今年春天有一本新书要出版，名叫《业余爱好者聚集》。阿拉巴马州议会将于2月7日恢复会议。他们计划研究移民法可能的修改。同时，法律的部分条款已被法院暂停。一些条款将在本届最高法院审理亚利桑那州移民法合宪性时提交审议。
Coming up, a bird that faces deportation. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一只面临驱逐的鸟。就在几分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, "Reap What You Sow." We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two, Ain't Nobody Here But Us Chickens.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选择一个主题，为你带来不同种类的故事。今天的节目，“种瓜得瓜”。我们已经到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕，这里除了我们这些鸡别无他人。
This next story is a story of friendship. You know, it is heartwarming when people come together, not knowing where things are going to lead, making choices that, as you'll hear, have consequences. Comedian Danny Lobell told this story in front of a live audience.
下一个故事是一个关于友谊的故事。你知道，当人们聚集在一起，不知道事情会走向何方，做出你即将听到的、有后果的选择时，是令人暖心的。喜剧演员丹尼·洛贝尔在现场观众面前讲述了这个故事。
About a year ago, in the summer, this took place. I'd been looking out my kitchen window for five years. And my backyard, well, it looked like a prison yard, really. It had a weight set that was rusted and smashed bottles and garbage everywhere and random barbed wire. I don't even know where the barbed wire came from. It was just there to make the yard look worse, I think.
大约一年前，在夏天，这件事发生了。我透过厨房窗户看了五年。我的后院，好吧，它看起来确实像个监狱院子。它有一个生锈的举重架，到处都是破碎的瓶子和垃圾，还有乱七八糟的铁丝网。我甚至不知道铁丝网是从哪儿来的。我想它就在那儿让院子看起来更糟。
And one morning, I woke up. And I said, that's it. That's enough. I can't take this anymore. I'm going to make this yard look good. And I go outside. And I take a garbage bag. And I start cleaning up the backyard, like 6:00 in the morning.
一天早上，我醒了。我说，够了。受够了。我再也受不了了。我要让这个院子看起来很好。我走出去。我拿了一个垃圾袋，开始打扫后院，就像早上6点一样。
My neighbors that I share a floor with are Ecuadorian gangsters. There's a bunch of them. And they all have the same nickname, Blanco. So we basically call them, like, Small Blanco, Medium-sized Blanco, and then there's the Main Blanco.
我同住一层楼的邻居是厄瓜多尔黑帮。他们有一群人。他们都有同样的绰号，“布兰科”（Blanco）。所以我们基本上称他们为“小布兰科”、“中布兰科”，还有一个“大布兰科”。
And the Main Blanco, around 11 o'clock, he opens his window. And he says, what are you doing? I said, I'm cleaning up this yard. And he said, all right, I'll join you. That's, like, the first time I've ever spoken to the Main Blanco in, like, five years of living there.
大约11点，大布兰科打开窗户。他说，你在干什么？我说，我在打扫这个院子。他说，好吧，我加入你。那是我住在那儿五年里第一次和大布兰科说话。
And he comes out. And we start cleaning this backyard together. And we're talking. And he tells me he'd been in juvy hall when he was younger. He may or may not have stabbed somebody. We don't know. But he learned how to draw there. And he was reformed by learning artwork. And he came out. And now he does tattoos out of his kitchen. So that explained why a lot of people were coming in and then leaving with bloody shirt arms and stuff. Questions were being answered, you know?
他出来了。我们开始一起打扫后院。我们在聊天。他告诉我他年轻时在少管所待过。他可能刺伤过人，也可能没有。我们不知道。但他在那里学会了绘画。他通过学习艺术而洗心革面。他出来了，现在他在厨房里纹身。这就解释了为什么很多人进来，然后带着带血的衬衫手臂离开等等。问题得到了解答，你知道吗？
And we're cleaning this backyard together. And as the day went on, some of the neighbors upstairs were like, what are you doing? We're like, we're cleaning the yard. It was like the Berlin Wall coming down. They're like, I'm coming to help. Let's do this. I guess everybody was as depressed as I was from looking at this backyard.
我们在一起打扫这个后院。随着白天过去，楼上的一些邻居问，你们在干什么？我们说，我们在打扫院子。那就像柏林墙倒塌一样。他们说，我来帮忙。做吧。我想每个人都像我一样，看到这个后院感到沮丧。
And so the whole building comes together. And we're cleaning this backyard together. And we did it. We got rid of the rusty bench press. That was it. It was like liberation.
于是整栋楼的人都聚集起来。我们在一起打扫这个后院。我们做到了。我们处理掉了生锈的卧推凳。就是这样。那就像解放。
And Blanco and I, we start talking and hanging out. And we had some beers afterwards. And I come up with this idea. I said, you know what would really be great to make this yard complete? Chickens. We should get some chickens.
布兰科和我开始聊天和交往。之后我们喝了点啤酒。我提出了这个主意。我说，你知道让这个院子完整起来最好的东西是什么吗？鸡。我们应该养些鸡。
I said, I'm done paying for eggs. That's a major expense in my life, eggs. And he was like, yeah, man. I'm in! Let's get some chickens! Let's do this!
我说，我受够了为鸡蛋付钱。那是我的生活中的一大开支，鸡蛋。他当时说，是的，兄弟。我加入！让我们弄些鸡！让我们做吧！
So he goes, where are we going to get chickens? And I said, live poultry shop. I see them all over. We could go to a live poultry shop. We'll get some chickens.
于是他说，我们去哪儿弄鸡？我说，活禽店。我到处都能看到它们。我们可以去一家活禽店。我们要买些鸡。
So we venture out to find a live poultry shop, Blanco and I. And we find one. And it's run by an Arabic dude. And we go in, and we go, hi. Yeah, we'd like to get some chickens. And we'd like to take 'em to go, alive.
所以布兰科和我冒险去寻找一家活禽店。我们找到了一家。它由一个阿拉伯小伙经营。我们进去说，嗨。是的，我们想买些鸡。我们想带走，活的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And the guy goes, my friend, we don't sell live chickens. It's not legal. We only weigh and fillet. And I'm like, well, just weigh and don't fillet. And he's like, no, fillet and weigh. Only fillet and weigh. And I'm going, weigh and don't fillet. And Blanco's just like, [BLEEP] this. We're going to steal a chicken.
那个人说，我的朋友，我们不卖活鸡。那是不合法的。我们只称重和去骨。我说，好吧，只称重，不去骨。他说，不，去骨和称重。只去骨和称重。我说，称重，不去骨。布兰科直接说，去他的。我们去偷只鸡。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
He's like, you distract him. I'm going to grab a chicken. So I go over to the dude, and I start talking to him. I think it's going to be quick. But there's some Benny Hill chase going on out of the corner of my eye with Blanco and the chickens.
他说，你分散他的注意力。我去抓只鸡。所以我就走到那个人身边，开始和他交谈。我以为会很快。但我的眼角看到布兰科和鸡之间发生了像《憨豆先生》式的追逐。
So I start talking to him. I'm like, what's the most chicken you've ever sold at one time? He's like, I don't know. Why would-- what do you want? You ever seen the movie Chicken Run? What?
我开始和他交谈。我说，你一次卖出的最多的鸡是多少？他说，我不知道。为什么——你想要什么？你看过电影《小鸡快跑》吗？什么？
And then he sees what's going on. He goes, what's your friend doing? And then Blanco hears, so he goes, oh [BLEEP]. Let's go! And he just runs out. And he's like, come on, we got--
然后他看到了发生了什么。他说，你的朋友在干什么？布兰科听到了，所以他说，哦，去你的。我们走！他跑了出去。他说，快，我们拿到——
I don't think we even needed to run out, but we did. And we just ran out with no chicken. We weren't even really caught. But we start running out.
我不认为我们甚至需要跑出去，但我们跑了。我们什么鸡也没带就跑了。我们甚至没被真正抓住。但我们开始跑。
And there was this Spanish dude who had been standing by and listened to the whole thing. And he calls Blanco over. He's like, yo, primo. And he says something in Spanish to Blanco, something like, [SPEAKING SPANISH].
有一个西班牙裔家伙一直站在旁边听完了整个过程。他叫布兰科过去。他说，嘿，表亲。他对布兰科说了些西班牙语，大概是[说西班牙语]。
And basically, what the conversation translated to was, I know a place where they do under-the-counter live chicken sales. And I'll tell you where it is. So he tells us about this place.
基本上，对话翻译过来就是，我知道一个他们进行私下活鸡交易的地方。我会告诉你它在哪儿。所以他告诉了我们那个地方。
And we go there. And it's run by Spanish people. And Blanco goes in, works his magic, all smooth, [SPEAKING SPANISH]. And the guy's like, si, si, si! Come, come! Takes us in the back. And he grabs a chicken, gives it to us.
我们去了那儿。它由西班牙人经营。布兰科进去，施展了他的魅力，一切都很顺利，[说西班牙语]。那人说，是的，是的，是的！来，来！把我们带到后面。他抓了一只鸡，给了我们。
And then he comes out, and he goes, you guys want a rooster, too? And he brings out this beautiful rooster. And Blanco's like, oh, that's an ill rooster, damn!
然后他出来说，你们想要一只公鸡吗？他带出一只漂亮的公鸡。布兰科说，哦，那是一只超酷的公鸡，该死！
And it was. It was a beaut-- I don't know if you've ever seen a rooster up close. They are beautiful animals. So we start talking. We're like, yeah, I guess we need a rooster to make these eggs happen. So we should take a rooster.
确实如此。那是一只美丽的——我不知道你是否近距离看过公鸡。它们是美丽的动物。所以我们开始谈话。我们说，是的，我想我们需要一只公鸡来让这些鸡蛋产出来。所以我们应该带一只公鸡。
Which is actually completely wrong, we found out, because the roosters really fertilize the eggs. And then they're completely inedible. But we didn't know that. So we're like, yeah, we'll take that rooster. Let's go.
这实际上完全错误，我们后来发现了，因为公鸡确实能让鸡蛋受精。然后它们就完全不能吃了。但我们当时不知道。所以我们说，是的，我们要那只公鸡。走吧。
And so we got this chicken and this rooster. And we're walking down Grand Street. And we feel like $1 million. We're like, we are going to change our lives. We're going to be eating fresh eggs.
于是我们弄到了这只母鸡和这只公鸡。我们走在格兰德街上。我们感觉像有一百万美元。我们说，我们要改变我们的生活。我们要吃新鲜鸡蛋了。
We get fancy. We start talking. We're like, yo, man. These hipsters are gonna be coming, knocking on our door. Organic eggs. We're gonna make a lot of money off this [BLEEP].
我们变得高级起来。我们开始聊天。我们说，嘿，伙计。这些文青会来敲我们的门。有机鸡蛋。我们要靠这个赚大钱。
So we're walking with these chickens. And we bring them home. What we didn't realize is we bought an old chicken, which was postmenopausal and had stopped laying eggs. It was at that point.
所以我们带着这些鸡。我们把它们带回家。我们没意识到的是，我们买了一只老母鸡，它已经绝经并停止产蛋了。就是那样。
And the rooster, from being in a dark, enclosed space for so long, had no concept of time according to the sun. It had a broken internal clock. So this rooster's, like, going off at all times, 5:00 in the morning, 3:00 in the afternoon, 8:00 in the eve-- just times you're like, really? Now, you're going off?
而公鸡，因为在一个黑暗、封闭的空间里待了太久，完全没有根据太阳判断时间的概念。它的生物钟坏了。所以这只公鸡在所有时间鸣叫，凌晨5点，下午3点，晚上8点——简直是你觉得，真的吗？现在，你要鸣叫？
But we loved this chicken and the rooster. We named the rooster Juanito. And the chicken was Dona. And the rooster's real smart. And they start sitting at my window or Blanco's window, depending on who's home when they're hungry, and even tapping with their little, scratchy claws.
但我们爱这只母鸡和公鸡。我们给公鸡取名叫华尼托（Juanito）。母鸡叫多娜（Dona）。这只公鸡很聪明。当它们饿的时候，它们开始坐在我的窗户或布兰科的窗户边，取决于谁在家，甚至用它们小小的、尖尖的爪子敲击。
So we start really falling in love with these chickens. And Blanco and Juanito start getting pretty close. Juanito's kind of learning his name. He'll be like, Juanito, Juanito! And he'd start running up on him.
所以我们开始真正爱上这些鸡。布兰科和华尼托开始变得很亲近。华尼托开始学会它的名字。他会说，华尼托，华尼托！然后它会跑向他。
And things are good for a while there. Little things started to pop up, like on the wireless signal, somebody named their network, like, "Shut Up Rooster." That was one thing I noticed. And then one day, randomly, on a telephone pole on the block, there was a sign that said, "Honk if you love roosters." But other than that, things were good. Life was good for a little while.
事情在那段时间里很好。小事开始出现，比如在无线信号上，有人把他们的网络取名为“让公鸡闭嘴”。这是我注意到的事情。然后有一天，随机地，在街区的电线杆上，有一个牌子写着，“如果你爱公鸡就按喇叭”。但除此之外，事情很好。生活在那段时间里很好。
Until one morning, I got woken up by knocking at my window. There was an Irish lady who was, like, seven months pregnant, who lived on the block. And it was early in the morning. She starts knocking-- [KNOCKING]. And I go, and I open the door. And she goes, shut your [BLEEP] rooster!
直到一天早上，我被窗户的敲门声吵醒。是一个住在这个街区的爱尔兰女士，怀孕七个月了。那是清晨。她开始敲门——[敲门声]。我去开了门，她说，让你那只公鸡闭嘴！
And I'm like, actually, it's a joint-owned rooster. But--
我说，实际上，这是共有的公鸡。但是——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
--go on. She goes, I'm pregnant! And that [BLEEP] rooster is waking me up at random hours in the day. And it's ruining my pregnancy. You've got to get rid of the [BLEEP] rooster.
——说下去。她说，我怀孕了！那只公鸡在白天随机时间吵醒我。它毁了我的怀孕。你得处理掉那只公鸡。
I'm like, all right, look. I'll talk to the other person whose rooster it is. And maybe we could figure this out. And I'm thinking, OK, well, this is obviously a delicate situation. She's pregnant. This ought to be OK to talk to Blanco about.
我说，好吧，听着。我会和另一位共同拥有者谈谈。也许我们可以解决这个问题。我想，好吧，这显然是个微妙的情况。她怀孕了。和布兰科谈这个应该没问题。
And I go, and he just flips out. He's like, white people are destroying the neighborhood. They're trying to take my rooster! And they're never getting it! I'm like, oh, [BLEEP]. This is worse than I thought.
我去谈了，他直接发火了。他说，白人在破坏这个街区。他们想拿走我的公鸡！他们永远也拿不到！我说，哦，去你的。这比我想象的还要糟。
And I'm like, look, you talk to her. I put him on the phone with her. And he disappears with my phone for a while. And then he just comes back and goes, it's all good. We worked it out. I'm like, really? It's worked-- what'd you say? He's like, don't worry about it. It's worked out. I was like, all right. That's good.
我说，听着，你跟她谈谈。我让他和她通电话。他拿着我的电话消失了一会儿。然后他回来直接说，没事了。我们解决了。我说，真的？解决了——你说了什么？他说，别担心。解决了。我说，好吧。那就好。
And like a week goes by. And then an inspector from the city shows up at our door. And Blanco comes over. He's like, [BLEEP], we've got to hide the rooster. It's a crappy old building. And there are these wooden floorboards in his kitchen. And we lift the floorboards. And we put the rooster underneath the floorboards.
过了一周左右。来自市政府的检查员出现在我们门口。布兰科过来。他说，该死，我们得把公鸡藏起来。这是一栋糟糕的老建筑。他的厨房里有木地板。我们抬起地板，把公鸡放到了地板下面。
And the inspector comes in. He's walking around. It's like that scene from Inglorious Basterds, you know? There is rooster!
检查员进来了。他在四处走动。那就像电影《无耻混蛋》里的那幕，你知道吗？公鸡在那儿！
But he's like, you guys got a rooster in here? And we're like, nope. No. He's like, I had some complaints that there's a rooster in this building. And we go, no, no, no. I think there's an injured cat on the block that has been making some noises. But there's no rooster here.
但他问，你们这儿有公鸡吗？我们说，没有。没有。他说，我接到一些投诉说这栋楼里有只公鸡。我们说，不，不，不。我想街区里有一只受伤的猫一直在发出一些声音。但这里没有公鸡。
And then, just then, the stupid internal clock on Juanito goes off. And he just, [CROWING], from under the floorboard. And we're caught red-handed. We're busted. And he's like, yo, you have a week to get that rooster out of here. Otherwise, you've got a $2,000 fine from the city.
就在那时，华尼托那个愚蠢的内部时钟响了。它鸣叫了一声，[鸣叫声]，从地板下传来。我们被当场抓获了。我们被抓住了。他说，嘿，你们有一周时间把那只公鸡弄走。否则，你们会被市政府罚款2000美元。
And then Blanco, I think he just decides he could probably connect with him on a minority level. And he's like, yo, man, white people trying to destroy this neighborhood! I've had that rooster since I was born! Which I don't even think is possible. I don't know how long roosters even live, but I'm pretty sure not 30 years. But the guy's like, no, you've got a week.
然后布兰科，我想他只是决定他可能能在少数群体层面与他联系。他说，嘿，伙计，白人在试图破坏这个街区！我从出生起就有那只公鸡了！我觉得这甚至是不可能的。我不知道公鸡能活多久，但我肯定不到30年。但那个人说，不，你们有一周时间。
At first, he's like, look, we split it $1,000 each on the fine. I'm like, you don't have $1,000. And I don't have $1,000. He's like, I'll double up on tattoos. We're gonna do it. I'm like, we're just going to keep getting hit with more and more fines. We've got to get rid of this rooster.
起初，他说，看，我们一人分担1000美元罚款。我说，你没有1000美元。我也没有1000美元。他说，我会加倍纹身。我们会做到的。我说，我们只会继续被罚越来越多的款。我们得处理掉这只公鸡。
He's like, I can't see anything happen to Juanito, man. I can't see it happen. I'm like, look, I'll deal with this. I'm going to get this done humanely. Nothing's going to happen. We'll find a place.
他说，我不能看着华尼托出事，伙计。我不能看着它发生。我说，听着，我会处理这事。我会人道地完成这件事。什么都不会发生的。我们会找个地方。
So I start calling farms. And it's, like, two days till D-day. We have to get rid of the rooster, or we get hit with a fine.
所以我开始给农场打电话。距离D-Day（最后期限）还有两天。我们必须处理掉公鸡，否则就会被罚款。
And I figured I only have one option. And that is a drop-and-run. And a drop-and-run is exactly what it sounds like. It's me going to a farm and dropping the rooster and then running.
我想我只有一个选择。那就是“放下就跑”。“放下就跑”听起来就是它的意思。就是我带公鸡去农场，把它放下，然后跑。
And I said, Blanco, you down to do this with me? I scouted out a good farm. We could do this. It's a humane farm. It's a petting zoo. They've got a pumpkin patch and kids.
我说，布兰科，你愿意和我一起做这个吗？我打探到了一个好农场。我们可以做这个。这是一个人道农场。这是一个宠物动物园。他们有南瓜地和孩子。
And he goes, it's too painful for me, man. You gotta do it on your own. You gotta to do it. I can't do it. I can't see Juanito go.
他说，这对我也太痛苦了，兄弟。你得自己做。你得去做。我做不到。我不能看着华尼托离开。
And the day comes for me to do this drop-and-run. And I remember Blanco sitting on the stoop, holding Juanito. And he is crying like I never saw him cry. He is bawling.
我去做这个“放下就跑”的那天到了。我记得布兰科坐在台阶上，抱着华尼托。他哭得我从来没见他哭过。他在嚎啕大哭。
He's kissing Juanito. He's like, my little dude. I hate to see you go. And I'm like, I gotta take him now.
他在吻华尼托。他说，我的小兄弟。我不愿看着你走。我说，我现在得带它走了。
The neighborhood perceived them both to be loud and annoying, and wanted them out of there. But if you got to know them, they're really pretty good dudes, you know? And I think it bothered him that there was really just nobody that would stick up for this innocent rooster. Thank you very much.
街区里的每个人都觉得它们既吵闹又烦人，想要它们离开。但如果你了解它们，它们其实是非常好的家伙，你知道吗？我想这让他感到困扰，真的没人会为这只无辜的公鸡挺身而出。非常感谢。
Danny Lobell. He's a comedian and an illustrator in New York City and @dannylobell on Twitter. He recorded this for us at the Upright Citizens Brigade Theatre.
丹尼·洛贝尔。他是纽约市的喜剧演员和插画家，推特账号是@dannylobell。他是在正直公民旅剧院为我们录制的。
[MUSIC - "NEIGHBOR, NEIGHBOR" BY JIMMY HUGHES]
[音乐 - 吉米·休斯的《邻居，邻居》]
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar and myself with Alex Blumberg, Ben Calhoun, Sarah Koenig, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Ship, and Nancy Updike. Dan Grech was Jack Hitt's producer in Alabama. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Seth Lind is our production manager. Emily Condon is our office manager. Production help from Matt Kelty, scouting help from Elna Baker, music help from Damien Gray, from Rob Gettes.
我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、本·卡尔霍恩、莎拉·柯尼格、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。丹·格雷奇是杰克·希特在阿拉巴马州的制作人。我们的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。塞斯·林德是我们的制作经理。艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。马特·凯尔蒂提供了制作帮助，埃尔娜·贝克提供了调研帮助，达米恩·格雷和罗布·盖茨提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
We first heard a version of Danny Lobell's chicken story on Kevin Allison's Risk podcast. The Risk podcast website is risk-show.com. That's risk-show.com Our website is thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our show by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who came back from his vacation in Colombia with this small package for the staff.
我们第一次听到丹尼·洛贝尔的鸡故事是在凯文·艾利森的“风险”播客上。该播客的网站是risk-show.com。即risk-show.com。我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ的管理层监督由我们的老板托雷·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他带着这个给员工的小包裹从哥伦比亚度假归来。
Drop them a little present, you know? Some snow, a little extra for them.
留点小礼物，你知道吗？多给他们一点雪，一点额外的“回馈”。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多关于美国生活的故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。